As we mentioned before, Unreal Engine will just package everything by default.
So if packaging size is really an issue for you, say you're shipping on mobile
or a certain console that really needs a specific file size, what,
what kind of things can we do to help reduce the package size here?
So got 10 tips.
I just want to note right on the outset that we don't have to follow
any or all of these tips, but if packaging size is a focus for you,
then some or all of them might be worth exploring.
So let's just dig into them.
You can start with an empty project.
So as I've been mentioning, you know, where we're starting with maybe the third
person template or the first person template, you can just start with an empty
project that comes with nothing.
And that will be the cleanest version.
You know, you won't have the starter content, for example, and, you know,
starting with an empty projects is a good first step.
Also as a project set in, there is an option to create compressed cooked packages.
Now I wouldn't, I wouldn't take this out of the box.
This is again, a heavy handed approach, but it will really try and compress
and squeeze down the most out of your cooked content that it can.
It's not needed for everyone, but again, if you're really, really looking to
squeeze out every megabyte here, you can look at the compressed packages.
You can also exclude editor content when cooking.
So the editor comes with, you know, cubes and skydomes and HDRI textures
and all these kind of great useful things out of the box that
help when you're building levels.
However, you could make a copy of some of them.
So you could copy the engine content over to your project,
your games content folder, and just make sure again, redirects are fixed
and all that good stuff, but if you do want to exclude the editor content,
again, this setting is found in project settings, you need to ensure that
you're not using that editor content.
Cause it will, you know, if you get a skydome that disappears or cubes
that disappear for some reason, you know, that's because you've
excluded the engine content when cooking.
So it can be a way to reduce the file size, but again, just make sure
you're not using that editor content.
Just to reiterate from a previous slide, development builds
are larger than shipping builds.
So if you're just deploying the development builds and thinking,
oh, why is our file size not going down?
Always just check that shipping build.
Cause that'll be your best bet at the file size of what your actual
build will be when you deploy the build, you can make sure you
cook only the maps that you need.
As I mentioned at the start, you can use a size map on your assets to determine
if anything is there that shouldn't be.
So say we had a blueprint and we use a size map, I've linked the URL
for how to use a size map here.
But if we use a size map on like a blueprint, for example, you can see
that maybe there's a skeletal mesh attached to the blueprint and maybe
that skeletal mesh is just a small skeletal mesh, but it's using 10 4k
textures and you're like, oh wow, I didn't know they were all in the blueprint.
And you just want to go through and like optimize some of the content.
So size map can be great for finding oversized content that
is unnecessary for your project.
Like I mentioned previously, we can migrate maps into a new project.
We can go through and remove any unnecessary plugins.
So your plugin window can be found under the edit bar and then plugins
next to where your project settings are.
I wouldn't just go through and untick all plugins because you may not know
what each plugin does and some plugins are needed for how you're
developing in Unreal Engine.
But if you know there's a plugin there that is unnecessary and it shouldn't
be enabled, just go through and remove it again, tread carefully, make sure
you know what that plugin is doing.
If you have to Google what the plugin is, do that, but removing unnecessary
plugins can help reduce file size.
There is a noodle texture plugin that is great for texture compression,
which you can look into.
And nano is a tiny project template for people who want to make
tiny games, UE4 and UE5.
So, you know, if you're really, if this is a passion project of yours and
you really want to squeeze out every megabyte, maybe you want to check
out the nano project there.